midi wants to know what motivates you to  continue any project like wine library  without seeing any significant growth  prior buddy you know for me that's a  very easy answer which is I just believe  in my holistic purpose right I'm blown  away by how many people are crippled by  one project or the other to me this is a  net net game I have a very clear vision  professionally where I want to go but  overall I just want to be a good human  being do business the right way the  right process put in the right hustle  and I control that if I don't get  results well that means I made a wrong  strategic decision but that doesn't  [ __ ] me either because there's a net  net I know where I'm going so for every  one or two times I decide to get in the  wrong business or invest in the wrong  thing I'm going to figure out a win  alongside of that and that's all that  really matters to me